The idea of cache obliviousness is
one of those great frontiers of HPC.
And it's a terrific starting point for
new research.
In particular, there's a lot of
solid theory but in my opinion there
haven't been quite as many successful
practical implementations or
evaluations of these algorithms.
Now if that's the case,
you might ask yourself, why bother
with cache oblivious approaches?
Well, there's at least one argument
that I find especially compelling.
Before I say it,
you should pause the video, and
see if you can think of
an argument on your own first.
[SOUND] Okay so,
what did you come up with?
Here's the one I like a lot.
The present and
future is about virtualized or
shared environments, like the cloud.
So, your program might have to fight for
resources, like caches or
network bandwidth, and do so
in an unpredictable way as other jobs
try to push yours out of the way.
In such cases, you might not have
a better choice than to try to be as
resource oblivious as possible.